what was like for you like can you can
you kind of pinpoint in your opinion as
somebody who you know obviously has a
crib out here and went to school out
here and was born here can you kind of
pinpoint the moment that you noticed
like America starting to kind of take a
a liking to the genre
um
definitely to me from my experience it
started like from Atlanta two cities
Atlanta New York
just like even going out you know I'm
saying like
like one thing I knew one of my friends
used to do he used to he was a big
baller he would go to the club and he
like spend so much money but he tell him
every time you know when you bring my
Butters out I want to hear this so right
you know what I'm saying so
the DJ's playing it you know I'm saying
the bottles coming out to the song you
know and the DJ is liking the music and
then that's that was like one of my best
experiences of like being in the club
and hearing it yeah and then you know it
started growing you know once the girls
like it once the girls like it it's over
it's over you know what I'm saying so
even like girls being in recovery with a
guy like yo can you play some afrobe
all right because you know girls like it
right you know let's do it it obviously
we can't because it was like a big big
thing in the UK first right no it was
from the UK yeah before you go to
America you know UK was like the first
place to acknowledge afrobe is like we
started doing Arenas in the UK first
crazy you know what I'm saying afrobeats
UK actually named it afrobeats so that's
like a UK it's like a UK term but then
you know we just ran with it you feel me
that's fire man what how much um can you
attribute to Drake embracing it to kind
of it being like easily bridge to the US
because I feel like once Drake Gets
behind anything for the most part it can
it can really take off I mean there's
this there's always narrative like oh
you know I'm saying afrobeats was was
definitely you know I'm saying huge it
was huge because if it wasn't he was
Drake Drake one yeah it was ready he was
like before Drake but you know Drake is
Drake right you know what I'm saying so
I'd be lying if I said you know so he
didn't put some Spotlight to you know
afrobeats you know what I'm saying um
and you know it was dope he's made some
dope you know records yo what there's
this like new trend
where there's the normal version of a
song and then the sped up version back
in the day I mean you're from the south
you know there was this Chopped and
Screwed [__] the screwed up [__] back in
the day shout out to Texas but now I
feel like every single there's like the
normal version and then they got the
special oh that's crazy you said that
because I released the album was out so
we released a couple songs then we
released the single again with a sped up
version yeah there's a sped up version
yeah it's crazy you know what I'm saying
um
I don't know some songs I don't even
know like some songs I see on like Tick
Tock and stuff you don't even know the
normal version yeah I'd be thinking
that's that's the original one when I
hit I'm like oh okay it makes sense now
I mean
social media is crazy though like it's a
different avenue when I started music we
used to talk about radio and you know
not now it's like podcasts
if you're promoting me before well just
promoting on like YouTube Facebook right
now you got like 20 apps yeah that you
know you gotta do your promo I know I
keep hoping that Tick Tock gets banned
so I don't have to worry about it
anymore
it's like one last day last day I'm like
if Tick Tock gets banned it just takes
one more thing I don't have to worry
about a way it was going crazy yeah yeah
are you pretty big on Tick Tock
um I mean I got a lot of followers but
I'm not like are you like on the app
scrolling and like diving into the
algorithm no no no no because it'll suck
you in bro yo and every time I get on
Tick Tock I'll be there for like two
hours like yeah cause whatever you're
into it knows yeah different and it's
everything's all there because I just
love like dogs and food so it just shows
me puffies and food I think it's crazy
how it can tell what you like yeah just
like being on the app after like a week
yeah he's like me I like food all those
cookies yeah just like guys who like
cooking a minute and like they're like
you gotta Cooks outside with the dog oh
yeah I love that [__] and then I just
bought a grill like a griddle like a
little Griddler thing outside so like
I'm like I'm always trying to find like
[__] to do on the grill you see the guy
that throws the butter on the thing no
but a pot and butter babe
you ever see the uh the guy who does the
shark bite at the restaurants shark bite
big Groove I think he African too funny
he might actually I interviewed him
um I think he might be I think so the
guy's just a massive human being
where's tattoos very tight clothes you
got to get them to do to do a dance to
yourself
um